traditionally the number one goal for
any company is to maximize profit for
shareholders but for quite some time now
we've seen a new breed of companies who
don't care at all about profit if these
companies are able to show large enough
user growth figures Nothing Else Matters
and I'm not just talking about random
background startups many of the most
recognizable startups in the world have
never made a single penny Zillow for
example loses around 200 million
per year Snapchat loses $1.3 billion per
year Lyft also loses $1.3 billion per
year but no one is as bad as Uber who
till just 6 months ago was losing $9
billion per year by far the main reason
for this is the insane growth this
everything perspective of modern
investors they're willing to stomach
insane losses not just for a year or two
but 5 10 15 years but it seems that
things are finally changing Ing and
they're changing fast in fact funding
has fallen off a cliff across the board
in q1 of 2023 Global funding had fallen
to $76 billion which is a 53% decline
from the 162 billion that it was the
year prior and this was despite two
massive deals with open Ai and stripe
who raised $10 billion and $6.5 billion
respectively without those deals funding
would have been down to 60 billion or
over a$ hundred billion less than 2022
you would think that the startups that
are affected most are the early stage
ones that are just getting started as
the risk with these companies are the
highest but it turns out that the
startups that are being affected the
most are actually the late stage
startups with insane valuations and a
chronic money burning problem as such
most of these companies are scrambling
to get their act together Uber for
example has been magically able to
reduce their losses from $9 billion per
year to just $300 million per year here
but not all startups are having such an
easy time as they're realizing that
becoming profitable isn't as easy as
they originally thought so join me as we
take a look back at how this new breed
of companies even came to be and what
this funding cut means for some of the
most well-known startups in the
world seeing all of these massive
companies constantly burn money it's
easy to think that that's just how Tech
works but that's completely false
companies like apple Google and
Microsoft pull in tens of billions if
not hundreds of billions of dollars in
profits every single year if you would
like to flip the script on these
companies and have them pay you for a
change then you may want to consider
investing in bonds and that's where our
upcoming Bond investing platform Silo
comes into play with Silo you can lend
money to the largest corporations in the
world as well as the US federal
government these institutions will use
your money to fund expansion efforts
research and development and growth and
in return for helping them grow they'll
pay you back your money with interest of
currently 4 to 7% if you'd like to do
that with no markups and the protection
of $500,000 in sipc insurance and a $2.5
million in FDIC Insurance please
consider checking out Silo in the
description below but anyway if you want
to build a massive tech company it seems
that you have to be willing to burn
money for at least the first 5 to 10
years but this is completely false in
fact this was never a thing with
traditional tech companies Intel for
example became profitable just 3 years
after being founded Apple became
profitable just 2 years after being
founded and even Google a modern tech
company only took 3 years to reach
profitability also it wasn't like these
companies were burning money on user
acquisition or marketing or insane
amounts of overhead rather they were
just just investing in getting their
first product to Market and as soon as
they were able to release their first
product they were able to become
profitable but all of this would change
with a company called Amazon unlike the
tech entrepreneurs that came before him
Jeff had a different perspective instead
of trying to sell a superior product for
a premium price which makes it easy to
achieve profitability Jeff wanted to
Center Amazon around killing margins his
catchphrase was literally your margin is
my opportunity but while this sounds
nice on paper it's not as clean an
application as this usually just turns
into a race to the bottom and that's
exactly what happened most of us only
remember Amazon and eBay but that's not
to say that they were the only players
in the e-commerce Market they were
simply the only ones who survived the
reality was that dozens of players
entered the e-commerce Market strapped
with the dotom funding this included
companies like boo.com webvan eoys and
pets.com to their credit many of these
companies actually did become quite
large web van for example was a grocery
delivery business that's eily similar to
instacart thanks to Doom funding they
were able to expand to 26 cities hire
3,500 employees and even have a billion
dollar IPO but scale wasn't the only
thing that these companies had in common
all of them were also burning ridiculous
amounts of money boo.com burned through
$135 million within 18 months months
pets.com burned through $300 million
within 2 years and as for web van they
were actually pulling in a good amount
of Revenue $178 million but their
expenses were wait for it
$525 million this meant that for every
dollar they pulled in they spent $3 and
it wasn't on building out their product
or new features or anything like that
almost all of the expenses of all of
these companies was just Marketing in
fact in fact bu.com spent $25 million on
Advertising before they even opened the
cost of the product itself was minuscule
for these companies compared to their
other expenses one of Bud Doom's main
Technologies for example only cost $6
million to develop but $135 million to
Market with these sort of Economics it's
no wonder why things eventually came
crumbling down with the Doom bust when
all of these companies went under after
this disaster though it seemed like
investors had fin finally learned their
lesson economics don't work differently
just because it's a shiny tech company
but somehow 20 years later we would end
up in the exact same position once again
so what in the world
happened likely the number one culprit
that normalized money losing Tech
Endeavors is Big Tech starting with of
course Amazon after the dotom bubble
Amazon was feeling the pain just like
every other dotom company but they had a
rather unique solution instead of just
trying to focus on profitability with
their retail business they decided to
just open up a whole new business called
AWS to pay for the unprofitability of
their retail business so essentially
they became their own funders and I
think we all know how this played out
Amazon would end up growing 500x and
become synonymous with online retail
despite the fact that they were never
able to consistently turn a profit to
this day seeing this many investors
would start feeling a bit of fomo maybe
they were right about the Doom companies
all along maybe all the companies needed
was a little bit more time and funding
to succeed after all it took 20 to 30
years for Amazon to reach their stride
if Amazon was the only instance of this
things wouldn't have gotten so out of
hand but they weren't which brings us
into our next culprit Google ever since
Google became profitable they've built a
career out of building no margin
negative margin products this includes
Gmail YouTube maps Android Google Cloud
the pixel and basically anything else
that comes out of Google their strategy
is to Simply reach as many people as
possible with these products and
monetize all of them using Google search
and Google ads once again this ended up
playing out extraordinarily well as
Google would end up growing 50x as they
grew multiple ubiquitous platforms with
billions of VI users each but all of
this was nothing in comparison to what
Zuckerberg would do Amazon and Google
were simply subsidizing one in-house
product with another in-house product
Zuckerberg however would go out of his
way to buy money pits just for the users
this of course included Instagram for a
billion dollar and WhatsApp for $19
billion while Facebook got a lot of
flack for these Acquisitions back in the
day these ended up becoming cash cows
Instagram is now Val valued at over a
hundred billion and WhatsApp is likely
worth even more these big tech companies
were clearly making a strong case for
pursuing money burning Endeavors but the
factor that pushed investors over the
edge was the exponential startups of the
late 2000s this of course starts with
Uber Uber was founded in March of 2009
and they're still not profitable but
they're worth 90 billion Lyft was
founded in 2012 and they're also still
not profitable but there were $4 billion
even after falling 90% door Dash was
founded in 2013 and they're still not
profitable but they're worth $30 billion
even after falling 50% similarly stripe
was founded in 2010 and is only now
becoming profitable but they're already
worth a hundred billion doar I could
literally name such companies Forever
Robin Hood coinbase GrubHub Airbnb
mongod DB Zoom affirm carvana pilo
Snapchat OCTA ravan paler pelaton
basically any startup that you recognize
and was founded within the past 15 years
likely Falls within this category as
dozens if not hundreds of money burning
startups were founded in the late 2000s
and early 2010s and went on to be
phenomenal Investments despite never
turning a profit with each and every
passing year investors and VCS were
becoming just a little bit more tolerant
of losses leading us straight into the
pandemic
[Music]
when the pandemic hit investor fomo went
into overdrive tech companies seemed
like a gold mine as everyone was sitting
at home spending all of their time on
phones computers and TVs all of the big
tech companies started hiring like crazy
as they thought this was it this was the
New Frontier the new era of tech
domination Mata nearly doubled their
employee count from 4 44,000 to nearly
990,000 Google also nearly doubled their
employee count from just over 100,000 to
nearly 200,000 at the same time big tech
stocks and pandemic stocks were going
insane and VCS couldn't help but feel
that they had missed out and this is
when they came to the conclusion they
may have missed out on this last runup
but they sure as hell weren't going to
miss out on the next runup and with that
they started puming money into basically
any startup that came through the door
with insane valuation and I think this
graph really showcases the essence of
what was going on back in 2012 there
were a healthy 5 to 10 new unicorns
every quarter this increased to 20 to 40
in the mid-2010s before rising to 5200
in the late 2010s but then suddenly it
would explode to 220 unicorns per
quarter in
2021 that's the same as over two
unicorns every single day and keep in
mind the stock market is only open to
252 days per year so really three
companies were reaching unicorn status
on any given day in
2021 and make no mistake this has
nothing to do with Rising Innovation or
more opportunity the only thing this has
to do with is VC funding and investor
greed I mean just look at this graph
funding literally grew 10x between 2011
and 2021 but the good news is that this
madness is finally coming to an end
which just leaves us with the question
what happens next well it's really
simple honestly a large number of money
burning startups will simply go bankrupt
this has already started to play out
within just the first half of 2023 338
us companies have filed for bankruptcy
54 of these companies had a VC or
private Equity backing meaning that if
this trend keeps up over 100 startups
will go bankrupt by the end of this year
alone and as interest rates continue to
stay High the economic pain for these
startups will simply get worse and worse
most of the startups that manag to fend
off bankruptcy for another year or two
will likely be bought out by larger
companies for rock bottom valuations if
things play out similarly to the Doom
crash only half of these companies will
make it past this initial Purge most of
the companies that make it through will
be a shell of their former selves with
no way to return to their all-time highs
if we look back at their stock graphs in
20 years it'll probably look something
like this now of course a select few
companies will defy the odds and not
only return to their former Highs but
make new highs these companies will
become the new Google Facebooks and
Amazon of the Next Generation but for
everyone else though this is pretty much
the end of the road as the VC money
printer has finally stopped Google is
definitely feeling a lot of this pain
themselves but it seems like they've got
a pretty good strategy to Pivot check
out this video to learn more but until
then I'm Hari and I'll see you guys on
the next one
[Music]